[Music]
this week we've got weaponize dumplings
constipated from birth wah and
successful accident taking away Tiffany
that's weird for our first story there
is this Indian politician art that has
declared war on killer Asian dumplings
what what what are those
yeah you guys not dumpling yeah like
this - yeah young darling
Oh soup dumplings my favorite army
through the iron shovel bomb column Bao
first time I had a Xiao long bao I
didn't know I had water inside so I eat
it what one oh the bird you know it kind
of splash like you know when your water
breaks I guess you'll be it was a lot
did it burn you know I just kind of
focus on the plate is okay yeah it's not
yet making those things it's very hard
you only think I punkin you know you
know how they make it well I tried
looking it up on a recipe and I try to
go back yeah it's like it's that it's
like collagen and fat that meat juice
yeah that's just not easy though man
like if you make the thing too thin and
it breaks that's why certain foods she
just goes order it dude I don't [ __ ]
make that [ __ ] at home even even if you
find like the second-best place it's
still really far in comparison I know
it's so much better wasn't you make it I
was like [ __ ] it can I all I do they
just make it their whole lives so let
them do it so good okay yeah so this
politician is saying that these Asian
dumplings are really dangerous and they
cause cancer and the losers are really
addicted to these dumplings like drop me
majors what what kind of dump are you
with right now what dumplings I did you
have the dumplings you guys are all so
what something I'll put on a lot normal
double Easter labeling as killer double
exactly not chemically killer well
that's a thing so they're saying that
there's a MSG in it and MSG is was
making this food so addicting of course
so unhealthy and that's causing cancer
and before our mystery different coffee
politician is saying that these are
killer Asian dumplings we got a ban it
you know you know what the funny thing
is it's like a epidemic for young people
like you know how it's like the new hip
thing like Paige it spinners or like
your sounds are cell phones are
polluting our children's minds
it's [ __ ] dumpling huh yeah this new
fad that's coming in from China food
things are way healthier than probably a
ton of the other stuff out there
I will say this I'm pretty sure a
hundred percent this man owns a
competing dumpling business it is put
out all he has a ravioli business
exactly Italian dumpling exactly he has
Indian right the [ __ ] Indian pot
stickers the hair in once those two
baffles business is going out of
business right now and that's my in
attacking the [ __ ] Asian dumplings
they're not your lambreaux dumpling I
know your plan or so they call these
dumplings Momo's and so many more yeah
the hashtag on twitter with hashtag
normal ban that's not fun I thought it'd
be like no mo mo mo o waiver comment
hire me oh mama
people started reacting on Twitter to
this ban so people for example worsening
here would you like to respect okay debe
man says in a country where more than
half the population sleeps without food
politicians are deciding what food tube
in brilliant hashtag politics hashtag
Momo ban really the half the population
is hungry there with third world man oh
yeah but half the population I didn't
know that's a lot because they have like
you know half their population is like
more than the whole entire us right I
heard like the whole country is like
slums like it's literally a skyscraper
and immediately it slums around like
the wealth disparity is heyou here right
that's [ __ ] up because they have like
a billion people how do guys watch the
movie lion no good it made me feel like
here we are like doing videos right
caring about our hair and our makeup
some there's these people in India and
these children who are being sold for
sex and people you know will blind them
with absolutely to take their money and
be the adult here really you know not
it's just like there's so much evil in
the world yeah I just like what can we
action what can we really do like we
need a sponsor Indian Superman creator
Indian are different matter
like we're going no but Joe offered a
solution
yeah another solution is going in some
sort of philanthropic like the start in
order to do [ __ ] and that's my power of
philanthropy gonna salt acid eyes I
don't know where we're going all quiet
done Indian women there's a lot of
Indian MMA fighters and you know what a
superhero
we need Indian Avengers yeah solution we
are going to give everybody India
goggles no more acid ice Oh glass
goggles we are the worst
oh that touch to help in India that's
what we mean you have all I don't I
don't watch Bollywood but do they not
have something like that all right no
but we need a real life no not like a
figure that just inspires others but
like a real real superhero in India that
maybe we can start like a organisation
where it's like fun to superhero right
and then all these Indian guys that want
to be crime fighters and they're like
our police is corrupt I want to do
something but I don't have the money for
an outfit or whatever because that's
more important than the others are bad
Ruthie Ranger what is that oh wow yeah
and we could create like you know like a
website where all these guys just submit
and they're like yo my superpowers did
they have a profile you could you could
fund them and then they'll go out fight
crime and then they'll love their stuff
like today I stopped the rape from
happening today I stopped the burglary
from happening today I saved the kid
whatever right oh I think that'll be so
good essentially what we're saying is
that if we are going to help you need to
laugh along the way too but I do like
that you're tackling the problems
through entertainment so I agree with
you
philanthropic stuff it's like so what we
started organizing the organization then
we pay the employees and you pay your
cell phone and how much goes there and
also what about the ceiling because
really it's about going there to giving
that child the bread or whatever and
then taking them away from that
situation but how can you actually do
that there's so many of them and that's
my problem of charities like I want to
donate but I don't know what's happening
with the money no they're stealing it
they're all corrupt or if over half the
population doesn't have food what we
need to do is just bake a giant pizza
right when have like 700 helicopters
lift up this pizza in the shape of India
aligned and slowly just lower it down
burn everybody alive as usually coming
down BAM
but that doesn't teach a man of onions
we got to teach a man of fish
okay we're eating them so they can learn
how to fish you know what really sucks
though we have enough food in this world
to feed everyone we produce enough food
in the US we produce it all over the
world it's just the logistics of it
isn't it worked out right because of
laws and politics and stuff like that if
there's no profit in it aren't on that
[ __ ] yeah but it just sucks like we
have the resources right now as a
species to come together feed everybody
we have more than enough but we can't
get it done you can't include you guys
eat leftovers all the
okay hell no not anymore I got money now
I throw that [ __ ] away are you for real
oh I don't want to carry it out my hag
is hired
is that why you're so lean now oh yeah
no I
Marguerite's fancy restaurants or
restaurants general you see half the
food they're like oh my god dude you put
on a buzzer give it to this person could
you do that I know I know what you mean
though it makes me feel bad for wasting
it yeah there's the other side of me
that's like I wasn't able to just order
off the menu without looking at the
price before so I'm gonna do it dim sum
style with entrees I do not feel good at
my ticket home oh but after I go I don't
want to carry it oh my god watch your
mouth back I don't wanna always talk
about this is I want to praise too much
about but just eat your food people
it just helps otherwise you're talking
to Joe all right Brian next sorry
there is this 22 year old man it's
actually a great transition after all
this food talk that's true so this man
his entire life has been constipated Oh
what does that I thought you died I
thought I was sure this man has never
been constipated once is that man he
doesn't know what it feels like we were
talking explaining to him he ding-dong
he didn't get what it was I don't get it
so healthy run yes I'm never pregnant so
yeah I'm constipated all the [ __ ]
time
oh gosh oh you never felt like one day I
don't want to poop today
no okay I don't want to poop yeah I just
don't care I just doesn't come out need
to poop but you just can't there's been
times in my past when I go days without
pooping that has never happened I poop
every day by choice a day you are still
healthy and if I want to poop like even
if I don't have to poop as if I'll poop
right now
ah you're something else yeah Cooper you
know what it is is that you so this is
when I just figured out right now he is
such an aggressive human being
oh and his body doesn't want to poop you
like threatening his body it's better
poop right now things are these
hemorrhoids yeah cool having a
conversation on the toilet you know what
time it is baby
that means you're the complete opposite
of this man so what happened with this
man is that he was born with future
sprung disease which means that the
peristalsis in his intestines which is
the thing that makes the muscles move
like a pillar shout everything it
doesn't work in him oh [ __ ] haha his
entire life he had to consecrated his
parents never thought it was a big deal
so they never knew - the doctor shows
care another year award for the [ __ ]
shooter literally oh [ __ ] so guess
siccola because when the poo poo stays
inside your intestine is soaking up all
the bad path but I was thinking isn't
feeling like can't you die from that so
it's crazy so this man he had been
trying to take laxatives throughout the
years work and I sort of didn't work
because all I could have does is it
pretty much concentrates all the water
in your intestines to help flush out
your your intestines but if your
intestines can't even who doesn't push
it out yeah then it's not gonna work my
goodness did the vacuum cleaner because
it studies all like it NMR no Kiwanuka
oh yeah you need to shop back in his but
it's trickle on and come with a chute
[ __ ] water up your ass and it just so
you just need a shot back and then get a
hair blow-dry professor about that turn
on
oh I'm not going to believe how much
[ __ ] they got I will I will believe it
we want to guess how many pounds 30
pounds for 20 years 29 pounds oh yes
good right here yeah 30 inches yeah
sorry it's 30 inches of his intestine
was rumored why was it removed all
because I was so inflaming so much [ __ ]
throughout all these years they had to
remove all of that because he was in so
much pain you imagine what that smells
like in that room uh so he hasn't [ __ ]
once no he would [ __ ] like a little bit
here and there but it was not any like a
soft-serve machine where it was all
loaded up and yet to pull the handle and
it comes out yeah great vigil pretty
much so you guys ready
pick your livers intestine expressing
wrong who were meeting ready so you had
to eat more to push from the top okay
right yeah oh my god why gotta move the
whole intestine this is intestine
[ __ ] baby seal
yeah it doesn't analysis you look at the
doctor Posey oh well he must have been
fat yeah they're saying that he looked
way more than nine months pregnant
thank you do they have it before pic as
I couldn't find that I couldn't find it
Heather so they're not showing the man
on she's literally full of [ __ ] anymore
so they remove the horn intestine
instead of cutting it open and taking
the Dookie out they can't save it
because it's so expensive if they went
like this would you have anything and
then closet it's pointless to have it
anyways because they don't even work
children to [ __ ] like nuts to [ __ ] that
he had but now or in taking it so what
I'm guessing what happened to this man
cuz it hasn't been reported that at
least I didn't find it is that this man
is just gonna have to live with the
colostomy bag for the rest of his life
I'm guessing that I don't know hey he's
better than death yeah true and being
full of [ __ ] god damn dude that look
like a huge earthworm that's what I was
yeah no I guess where he was wrong China
China that's why it's parents were like
I don't care about the big deal yes
what a [ __ ] I found just pregnant so
normal how old house right two years old
the three-hour operation what about the
baby you didn't prove yeah you did it
and that's the thing like the parents oh
my god that would a sudden do kidding me
eat nothing and every day is Asian
parents are calling fat you are so fast
was I going to explosion do it is not so
Prada feels really good now I know he
feels great now the b-boy now I don't
know this as really I feel like I would
feel more relieved if it goes out of my
[ __ ]
instead of just taking I still feel like
I was cheated it doesn't realize he
doesn't even know that feeling that's
true could you imagine if he had to [ __ ]
it would just fill up the toilet all the
way to the [ __ ] brim that's worse
than this yeah that's like five of these
but you agree that it would feel
satisfying if it feel that like if I
felt like give me a visual of what I've
been feeling you know that guy thing I
have all this [ __ ] like let me just like
let it all out [ __ ] whack you feel
like you just did some gymnastics in you
went you can probably support or party
to it cause it's like a porta potty so
much yeah I rather to just be a bit of
like blue liquid with Dookie and toilet
paper colors of Dookie - everyone's
Dookie different colors for a last story
there was this Good Samaritan driver
that rammed into a car that was in this
high-speed police chase oh wow you ran
into the police officer No
I got you salsa's so this takes place in
Detroit there's this 26 year old man
named Colby he was fleeing the police
car before I am now and I'm going to
show you guys the shape oh we got a baby
oh yes director another voice I'm sure
they don't work when they need him for
[Music]
which one is the one the car right in
front right oh that's a theater and the
regular clock the street Tiffany is
turning into is nothing although don't
go to Walmart oh that's dangerous
I'll be kind of back I came out put the
[ __ ] up
I always want to be a police officer
boss now
cops love the car and sure I would do
that Gary I probably would not be a very
good cop that he made me do all that
work I would some other places slapping
on the backside of his hedges
asian-style dude I think that's why
they're so aggressive when they come out
do [ __ ] up and chase you for five
miles
yeah yeah they also found I was off work
three hours later overtime it's my girls
freaking birthday party yeah exactly
that's how police brutality yeah they
all had breaking parties to go if you
ever see a kiss my daughter's first
Facebook game you made me miss perky pop
game you piece of [ __ ] I don't think you
can get police brutality for smacking
somebody upside the head
oh it's not a punch you're just mad all
right but it looks like you're
chastising your child yeah I mean thank
you or you just pulled pants down for
spanking yeah Fat Boy possible it should
be the rule for all four chases after
the car chase the cop pulls you pants
down and smack every time you sound like
a cholo fragile [ __ ] cholo ship hey
wash our car going to be covered by
senior boys coming out as own pocket I
was thinking the same thing too well I
do know that the police department did
upload this video and like thank that
Good Samaritan really because people get
in trouble for getting like even helping
and getting themselves in danger and
stuff like that but he had his daughters
t-ball game yeah so he's grateful yeah
so this is the man that 26 years old
remember that because he does melancholy
this oh no well part of his 26 exact 40
yeah so this dude when they arrested him
they also found 10 bundles of heroin in
his car so we keep hearing about these
heroin Darren heroine stories I know
it's going on with all his heroin stuff
crazy that he looks like some kind of
sea animal like a seal or something yeah
I see that
[ __ ] what's the producers name that was
dating Joe Jackson
Jermaine Dupri yeah madam looks like
Jermaine Dupri and Method Man had a baby
yeah and then they obviously [ __ ]
himself in the face or something yeah oh
man
yep but luckily here stop and I could
see Mary would you have done that
Tiffany me are you crazy
oh wow okay good mind if I had a bad
like that I'm saying are you crazy for
many reasons because one you know I
don't spring into action like that -
you're not a good person
I'm not a good person to be more scared
about me dying than kind of helping me
you got a [ __ ] kid to think about the
kids not in there so but things the kids
don't need to mom oh my god you are such
a [ __ ] okay think about your kids
no no Bart with a [ __ ] rumble [ __ ]
over that dude I stayed with a truck if
I had a company van that was I'm a dirty
bag all day but tell me y'all looking
for FedEx it had a free [ __ ] vanna
drive around oh yeah Tim my car right
now all going on the grass dude not even
with your truck because what opportunity
you ever have to fight to share truck
okay I make payments on that truck - no
have battle scars on the truck
no that truck will go over the car and
then I get out and then can't do that
for all time you forgot that your kid
was in the back you know in the key of X
my dad's here oh yeah
Oh that'd be so cool one of all my
positive people I want to hear your
thoughts put it in the comments below
because if you're negative shut the hell
up and go drink some raid please but if
you're very pong to leave it in the
comments below for the last video over
here
[Music]